Pope Francis condemned
surrogacy there have been some other
unfortunate things that have come out of
the Vatican an embarrassing book about
using all sorts of bizarre sexual
language from the the person who is now
the head of the dicastri for the
doctrine of the faith once called The
Holy office once called the Inquisition
you know the the doctrinal office of the
Catholic church and there's this kind of
odd book I won't even get into it
because a lot of it seems even kind of
obscene and so there was anyway there
was bad news coming out Catholics were
feeling a little bit low and then all of
a sudden we got this good news from Pope
Francis
and it's it's worth repeating because
the the people who think that Pope
Francis is just purely a liberal the
kind of liberal leftwing atheists who
applaud Pope Francis without without
reading everything that he has to say
they're going to try to paper over this
one but it's important he's not just
talking about IVF here which is totally
condemned and unacceptable according to
Catholic teaching he's not just talking
about certain kinds of surrogacy uh
homosexual couples renting out a womb
which is a phrase that Pope Francis used
as uterus for rent uh it's not not even
just that it's not just you know the
commercialization it's all of it Pope
Francis says I deem deplorable the
practice of so-called surrogate
motherhood which represents a grave
violation of the dignity of the woman
and the child based on the exploitation
of situations of the mother's material
needs but Francis goes on to say child
is a gift end quote never the basis of a
commercial contract and he has called
for a global ban on surrogacy quote to
prohibit this practice
universally to prohibit what he calls
quote uterus for rent totally totally
right here three cheers for what the
Holy Father has said very very
important and the fact that Pope Francis
has some cache among liberals and non-
Catholics and non-christians and big lib
atheists I I hope we'll we'll allow this
message to resonate more because it's a
new bioethical issue we don't have 2,000
years of experience of surrogate
motherhood it's it's just a a
development that came about because of
modern technology so a lot of people
don't know how to think about it
bioethic and in our modern culture even
many
conservatives have just accepted as if
by osmosis so many premises of
liberalism and the commercialization of
everything we don't think about it but
that's just the world we live in and as
a fish is unaware of the water in which
he swims so too we are unaware of so
much of the liberalism and the
commercialism and the materialism that
we walk around in but Francis Pope
Francis says it very well here he says
is a child is never the basis of a
commercial contract it is a grave
violation of the Dignity of the human
person to do this even when there are
the best of intentions even when it's a
couple struggling with infertility I
know I Bri we briefly went through it
fortunately there was a a very mild
intervention that worked and so it was
no big deal but for a couple years we
went through it so I know how profoundly
painful that can be what a strain that
can put on marriages and people will say
well look if if a couple's struggling
with fertility what's the big deal of
using a
surrogate the big deal is you are
treating a child as a as a commodity to
be purchased rather than a gift from God
the only person who can be said to have
any rights when it comes to procreation
is the child and the child has a right
to his natural mother and father join
together in holy matrimony and to be the
product of the conjugal Act of his
parents okay and and the the more we
Tinker around with this the uh worse
things are going to be because we will
be and we are not even aware of this but
we will be establishing the domination
of Technology over the very origin and
Destiny of human life a good example I
think of this is a is a lawsuit that
came up just this year was back in April
I think it was where a couple struggling
with infertility went to one of these
quack doctors and you know they managed
to collect the sperm in a way that is
Gravely immoral and they got an egg in a
way that's extremely evasive and all
extremely expensive by the way and then
whoopsy Daisy they mixed things up and
they created a child with the wrong
sperm and egg so this is not just even a
case of embryos being mixed up and you
know the black baby comes out of the
Chinese lady and you know white baby
comes out of the Mongolian I don't know
whatever I but this was a case of a
human being was
created whose parents had never met and
whose parents I believe in this case
were married to other people at least
one of them was I think both of them
what do you do about that person well
it's a fringe case yeah it's a fringe
case because you've engaged in an action
that is intrinsically disordered and
Gravely immoral and so what do you say
well you know look well if this happens
one time out of a thousand that's just
life right no you've created a human
being because you've you've reversed the
order of responsibility of of parent to
child and you've treated people like
property to be purchased a a person is
never a property to be purchased and
owned you've disres respected the rights
of of a person and you've done so for
the best of intentions sure the road to
hell is paved with very good intentions
and this is a great
clarification it's sad that it's even
necessary but it's a good clarification
from Pope Francis right now go to
hall.com what is a better New Year's
resolution than building a daily habit
of prayer and meditation prayer is
necessary for flourishing and to get the
help that you need in the habit of
praying you might check out hallo hallow
is the number one Christian Prayer app
in the United States it has helped many
people maintain a daily prayer routine
and it can help you too download the app
for free at hall.com
kwes you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way not
sure where to start check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in the year
available on the Hallow app for brief
daily readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cavel even
some world-class athletes with hallow
you can customize a personal prayer plan
that works for you listen wherever you
are with downloadable offline sessions
ultimately we will learn how we can
become better individuals despite this
broken World maybe maybe aided by this
broken World in a way as we strive to
become more like Christ in our daily
lives through prayer fasting and giving
you owe God your prayer and the only way
to become holy is to pray so go pray
download hallow at hall.com
kenlees get an exclusive three months
free 3 months absolutely free hall.com
the hill which is a Center leftish news
Outlet is is reporting in an oped so
this is an opinion piece that DeSantis
will drop out after
Iowa uh this oped from the hill says
I've heard from two people very familiar
with the disantis campaign a major donor
in a high level political operative that
if the Florida governor loses the Iowa
Caucasus to former president Trump as
expected on the night of January 15th he
will either drop out of the race that
night or make his announcement the next
morning and then there's an editor's
note here on the SED says the disantis
campaign vigorous ly denies this
assertion this oped has been updated to
include the following statement from the
campaign Ronda santis is in this for the
Long Haul
okay I think both statements are correct
actually I think it is likely that if
DeSantis loses Iowa that he will drop
out but I also believe that the Des
santis campaign is telling the truth
which is that the campaign's going to
stay in it as long as it can the the
reason for this is I spoke to a friend
of mine who who is very familiar with
presidential campaigns and he told me we
were going back through some of the
older presidential campaigns 2012 when
this candidate dropped out and this
candidate I said well I think he dropped
out for this reason and he dropped out
for that reason and my friend said
Michael presidential campaigns end for
one reason and one reason only because
they run out of money that's why they
end that's why people just because they
can't go on any further now DeSantis had
raised a ton of money Dan santis
campaign also burned a ton of money but
if the DeSantis campaign looks at Iowa
sees that they're going to lose and who
knows maybe they'll pull a huge upset
and then looks at New Hampshire sees for
sure they're going to lose and then
looks at this state and this state and
this state the only way they could even
possibly make a claim to be able to
compete in some of these states is to
spend oodles and oodles of cash they're
not going to be able to raise any more
money when the donors smell blood in the
water and the campaign will end then
they'll be in it for the long haul but
circumstances ha have a way of forcing
the hand of candidates and it can happen
really quickly we've just gone through
what 16 18 months already of of
candidates running or signaling that
they're going to run or starting to
raise money and it's going on for a
really long time and nothing has really
happened the minute that voting starts
the minute you see the Iowa caucuses the
minute you see some of those early
primary States things are going to
winow
pretty pretty quickly I think have you
yet subscribed on YouTube to this
channel you haven't what that's crazy do
it you have to do it that way you'll get
more of this cool content
man ring the bell see you next time